chugi is that like korean hey what's up
i'm rob wilson and i'm here with
buzzfeed and i'm gonna test my gen z
knowledge
i'm generation
i think i'm gen x i think i'm not gen z
that's definitely not me i'm 42 years
old guys so i'm that generous
but i'm gonna test what i know about you
young folks and we had a lot of cool
kids in the movie that are gen z so
hopefully i picked up some stuff from
them all right so here is the first
question which of these songs is not by
olivia rodrigo okay obviously i know
olivia rodrigo i met her at halloween at
a cool party good for you
brutal happier than ever or deja vu so i
definitely know good for
you
and deja vu
i think is hers and i think her other i
think i'm gonna say happier than ever
i'm gonna click on that correct yay
say i know i know my olivia rodrigo guys
who is this and it's got a picture
zendaya
rowan blanchard
millie bobby brown
or emma chamberlain okay well i know
it's not zendaya or millie bobby brown
because i know i know those two girls um
oh gosh
rowan
i'm gonna click
oh wrong emma chamberlain
i'm sorry emma i don't know you as yet
but
awesome picture and which platform
launched her career i see and now i'm
going to get this wrong because the
options are tick tock twitter youtube
and instagram so i'm gonna guess tick
tock because that's like the youngest oh
no i'm wrong youtube oh maybe i should
have damn when would you use the term
sus
when you're describing something
suspicious or suspect
to tell someone
shut up sis
to compliment someone's super cute style
or to abbreviate the word suspenders
i would say
what first stands out to me is when
you're describing something suspicious
or suspect is that it
yes that's it okay yeah we have sus in
australia like yeah i know what that is
john b sarah kai is it k.i.e
pope and jj are characters in which show
oh gosh i've been i've watched 10
billion shows here are the options never
have i ever
outer banks
euphoria
and sex education oh
i've watched a little bit of euphoria
and sex education but like not the whole
not the whole thing and i haven't seen
the other two oh
i'm gonna just say guess and say sex
education oh i'm wrong it's outer banks
ah see i've never i haven't seen that
show is that a netflix show damn i'm
failing the test so far okay which of
these is a popular tick tock dance
renegade the cupid shuffle gangnam style
and single ladies i think the single
ladies is beyonce a gangnam style but i
think that was before tick tock slightly
um
oh gosh
i watched some tick tock dances but i
don't know what they're called i'm just
gonna say the cupid shuffle
oh i'm wrong
oh damn
and there's charlie dimelio i actually
met her at the super bowl i was renegade
damn okay i'm not very gen z who is this
okay and then there's a picture on this
gentleman running low on battery shawn
mendes jack harlow
the kid leroy you know what i really
should know what the kid leroy looks
like because he's australian but i don't
know what he looks like i only know his
songs um and or little baby oh
oh i'm gonna guess because of his pale
skin i think jack harlow is british i
think so i'm gonna click him
yes
i got one right that was like powers of
deduction okay he's from kentucky guys
correction who knows why i thought he
was british i just maybe because his
name's jack well
whatever which of these spongebob
screenshots is not a popular reaction
meme i'm gonna say this one with a
little crab thing
oh i'm wrong
that was a popular one
it's this one this one isn't one
oh
woman freak best friend and get into it
is sung by which musician
ariana grande little nars ex dozier cat
or rosalia ariana grande pretty sure oh
no i'm wrong wait i okay i did that too
quickly guys i i did actually i should
have known that which tv show is this a
screenshot from is it fake the winx saga
elite heart stopper
ginny and georgia
i think elite is all guys so i don't
think it's from that
ah
oh god and i haven't seen the other i'm
gonna say ginny and georgia am i oh i'm
right
it just sounded like girly and there's
girls in the picture finally according
to gen z which is
the chooky way to wear your hair what's
that
slicked back bun a center part
protective style
or a side part chugi
is that like korean
just gonna say
slicked back bun
oh i'm wrong
okay and now i've got my final score
guys i'm 4 out of 11. it was side part
was the correct answer okay 4 out of 11.
clearly yes sadly you're not one of the
youths yeah great i know i'm old um but
at least you're old enough to legally
drink yeah i am so you know
and to rent a car i don't know whether
some of you gen z's can't do that you
gotta be like 25. i would have thought i
would have done done better but it goes
to show you i am old
and that's why i'm playing the older
stephanie in the movie and the younger
stephanie is played by angeli rice he's
like really young and he's in spider-man
movies and cool stuff thanks buzzfeed
and everybody check out senior year
coming on netflix may 13.
[Music]